philippine president rodrigo duterte
says he's dropped plans to run for vice
president and will retire from politics
when his term ends next year
opponents had questioned whether it
would be legal for the controversial
leader to run as the constitution limits
presidents to one term in office the
idea was unpopular with the majority of
filipinos duterte now saying he's heard
the will of the people
the overwhelming i said
sentiment of the filipino is that
i am not qualified
and it would be a violation of the
constitution
to circumvent the law
the spirit
of the constitution
[Music]
joining us now from manila is political
scientist richard heydarian who's
written widely on duterte and
philippines politics richard this is
quite a turnaround by duterte just
picking up on that statement we just
heard has the president simply run out
of political capital
well i mean one thing we have learned
about populist over the past five years
or so is that you know uh we should not
take them literally but we should then
take them seriously no but sometimes
perhaps we should also take them
literally uh and and in this case it
seems president duterte is beginning to
realize the tide is shifting and turning
against him so up to 60 percent of
filipinos including a majority of people
from his home island of mindanao where
he has almost 100 percent support right
throughout the years opposed his plan to
run as a vice president uh because many
people see that as a potential backdoor
for him to once again become a president
even though uh the philippines post mark
ocean post-dictatorship constitution
wanted to make sure we don't have
another dictator that's why
our presidents are only confined to a
single six-year term uh his approval
ratings while still high especially by
you know western standards uh they have
also suffered double-digit declines over
the past few quarters and a lot of his
allies including senator emmanuel manny
pacquiao
are now turning against him uh so i
think he's realizing that he's hitting a
peak so i think perhaps this is a peak
to territory situation and duterte is
also
accordingly trying to retrench his
position in philippine politics now this
speculation his daughter will run for
president tell us a little bit about her
well sarah duterte is now leading the
survey of potential contenders for
presidency
next year but she is on a downward
trajectory uh she our numbers were
around 28
so she was not really a clear front
runner uh as we saw in the past there
were candidates who had 30 40 of the
support heading into the president's
presidential elections and didn't win
like former vice president uh binay uh
she her numbers were pretty good but
they're on a downwards uh you know
trajectory she went from 28 percent in
the third quarter of the second quarter
of this year to around 20 and now she's
statistically tied with uh ferdinand
marcos jr bongbong marcus so i think the
other big factor we're not talking about
so much is the rise of the marcosus no
and this uh and the lone sun and the
scion of ferdinand marcos uh the marcus
family which used to dominate the
philippines during the dictatorship days
yeah indeed i just wanted to touch on
the icc investigation as well the
international criminal criminal court
has opened an investigation into
duterte's so-called war on drugs now if
human rights abuses are found to have
taken place how likely is it that he'll
face prosecution
well this is the reason why president
duterte was contemplating running as a
vice president which is quite
unprecedented we had a situation whereby
vice president became a president and
ran for vice presidency but the reverse
of that is quite unprecedented and one
reason was i think president duterte
himself admitted no he was he's looking
for some sort of illegal immunity from
potential prosecution of by
international criminal court and we have
the global magnitsky app so he could
also face personal sanctions and other
measures from uh us congress from from
legislators from around the world
potentially from european union so we
don't know if that's going to happen but
i think the fear of that or concern
about that was one big reason behind why
duterte initially was considering vice
presidency but if you look at the latest
surveys he's well behind uh other
candidates especially senate president
uh vicente soto is 11 points
ahead of him so i think the third is
realizing that that even if he wants to
run for vice presidency or something
like that he's going to have a hard time
so perhaps he's really reconsidering his
options but this is duterte you know
this is a guy who was a substitute
candidate in 2016 elections so we don't
know until 11th hour or past 11th hour
what really his plans are but clearly
we're seeing a peak duterte situation it
seems his popularity and political
capital are no longer where they used to
be all right richard we're going to have
to leave it there political scientist
richard heydarian in manila thanks very
much